Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, I bring you
today exciting news of medical advancement.
We now have seen an individual healed from
his paralysis merely through the prayer of
a Christian preacher.
This now will allow us to heal so many people.
I never knew It was so simple.
Take a look at this incredible video of a
Christian preacher restoring the movement
and feeling in a man's paralyzed hand.
And he did it on a stage with music playing.
If you can imagine.
Speaker 2: This, John.
Okay.
He's an electrician.
Four years ago, he was in a work accident
where he got completely shot.
He lost feeling in his left hand.
He said today, when you call that out earlier,
someone has numbness.
He said he started feeling a tingling sensation
in his left hand and in prayer.
He started moving his hand in faith.
He now has mobility and feeling in his left
hand.
Wow.
Long time is.
It's time to do it.
I feel a tingling.
I think it needs more because these fingers
are not going straight.
Yeah.
I got a lot more movement.
And let's pray.
Complete miracle tonight in Jesus name.
Pray, pray, praying.
Let this miracle be done.
Speaker 1: Folks, pray harder.
Speaker 2: In the name of Jesus.
Look at that.
Do it again.
That's it.
Are you seeing this?
Lord, touch him with your power.
Let this miracle come to pass.
Speaker 1: The guy now has fainted.
No.
Give him that grace.
But his hand is moving perfectly.
Even though the guy is unconscious being too
close.
Speaker 2: That hand even now.
In the name of Jesus.
Pick him up for a second.
How shaken up about this are you right now?
Tingly.
Like I just got electrocuted.
Speaker 1: What is that?
Was at the wrong hand there.
Speaker 2: Well, this electricity's good,
my brother.
This one's good.
Look at that again.
Oh, my goodness.
Can we give Jesus a mighty.
Speaker 1: Hand to pray?
Remember, it's not the preacher.
It's Jesus that's doing it.
I genuinely hate this stuff.
Now, sometimes the the person being healed
is a part of the scam, and sometimes the person
being healed is sort of a victim.
And we've seen every scenario with this.
Okay?
Sometimes it's an individual who is never
actually paralyzed, for example.
Sometimes what can happen is there's sort
of like a surge of energy.
There's like an endorphin release and you
might temporarily think you're healed.
You know, there's often like the ones who
I haven't walked in 40 years and then they
stand up and they push their their cane away
or their walker or whatever.
And then it turns out they weren't really
healed.
They had like a, you know, just a surge of
energy.
And they could have briefly stood at any point.
But it doesn't mean that now they can walk
or anything like that.
But sometimes the person being healed is just
out and out part of the scam.
And it's all a lie, as as I'm sure you can
imagine.
And I continue to say, show me a single faith
healer who can regrow the amputated limb of
an individual.
That would be something that is much less
ambiguous, although you could probably make
a scam with that, too.
Right.
I mean, David Copperfield makes it look like
he splits people in half.
So you could you probably could make someone
look like they're missing a limb and then
it grows back or whatever.
But you understand what I'm saying?
Do something like that.
And then we might be able to talk about it.
But this goes back a very long time preachers
who claim to have cured people of afflictions,
and it's a rowdy sort of revival style crowd.
And sometimes people from the crowd are called
out.
Sometimes symptoms are called out and people
volunteer themselves.
And again, you don't know if they're victims
or if they're scammers or whatever the case
may be.
And sometimes there's a physical laying of
hands on them, sometimes there isn't.
We've seen fake surgery.
We've seen all all of this stuff.
And of course, there's no evidence that any
of it is miraculous.
And again, we could test this.
We really could.
You know, I'm going to I'm going to tell you
the way it could be done.
And we all know that these faith healers would
never subject themselves to it.
But if you really wanted to do this, you could
go to the faith healers.
You could go, okay, listen, let's make it
fair.
Give me the list of conditions you could cure,
that you could heal.
None of them would say, I can regrow an amputated
limb that would never be there.
They will go, Well, I can cure problems of
the of the stomach, you know, stomach pains
I can cure and headaches and tingling, numb,
whatever.
Get the get the actually get the list from
them of the stuff.
And then you do a controlled experiment.
And then, of course, we all know if any of
these folks could really do this stuff.
It would be immediately praised by the medical
community.
It would be studied and praised if it was
determined to be real.
Now, I know many of you will say, David, the
Western medical community would never acknowledge
faith healing, because if faith healing were
real, they would be out of a job they wouldn't
need.
You wouldn't need doctors anymore if faith
healing were real.
Okay.
Yeah, I understand the motivation claim that
you're making, but the medical science community
studies everything.
You know, people like to say We we've never
studied the effect of giving people high doses
of niacin for depression.
Actually, we have studied that.
There's many studies about that.
And I guarantee you, especially the medical
researchers that are not part of Big Pharma
would be glad to evaluate and study this and
we would all know if it were actually a real
thing, but they never subjected themselves
to it.
So this can be dangerous in that some people
accept it as an alternative to seeking real
medical treatment.
It's often fraudulent.
It often is weaponized against people with
little financial means.
So they're there in the first place, maybe
because they can pay 40 bucks to go into the
revival tent rather than what it might cost
for for real treatment.
And that's a problem with the medical system,
of course, which we've talked about.
But let's rely on evidence based medicine.
And I don't know what else to tell you, but
this is truly horrible stuff,